once men turned their thinking over to
machines in the hope that this would set
them free
but that only permitted other men with
machines to enslave them
[Music]
[Music]
dune is the greatest sci-fi series ever
written the story of dune spans over the
course of five thousand years in six
novels titled dune dune Messiah Children
of Dune God emperor of dune heretics of
doom and chapter house doom in dune the
all-female order of superhumans known as
the Benin Jesuit have been active for
thousands of years through selective
breeding they carefully honed their
abilities the ultimate goal of the Benin
Jesuit was to produce the key SATs
hadurok the super being of the universe
a male many Jesuit with perfect sight of
the future and the past he would be able
to look where they could not and he did
come though not as they expected the
planet Arrakis also known as dune is the
only planet in the known universe where
the spice melange is found the spice is
a drug that is used throughout the
Imperium for various purposes mainly its
geriatric properties the spice is life
and can more than double the human
lifespan in some special people such as
the highly trained many Jesuit Reverend
mother's the spice melange can awaken
prescient vision sight of the future the
spice also heightens awareness and is
used by the guild as a means for space
travel gifting them with precedents
which they use to navigate the spice
melange is the gasoline of the universe
without it all commerce throughout the
known inhabited galaxies would cease the
spice melange is also highly addictive
once addicted one must continue taking
the spice or else they will suffer spice
withdrawals which are always fatal
the spice he said it's in everything
here the air the soil the food the
geriatric spice it's like the truth say
you're drunk it's a poison she stiffened
his voice lowered and he repeated a
poison so subtle so insidious so
irreversible it won't even kill you
unless you stopped taking it we can't
leave Arrakis unless we take part of
Arrakis with us before the events of
doing the fiefdom of Iraq is rested with
the Baron Harkonnen the sworn enemy of
Duke Leto Atreides of the planet Caledon
but when the impure of the Imperium
shadow Macrina the fourth felt
threatened by the Atreides influence and
potential power he devised a plan to rid
himself of House Atreides he used the
feud between the harkonnens and the
Atreides as cover
after the fiefdom of Arrakis is handed
over to House Atreides which includes
Leto his concubine the Binnie jesuit
lady Jessica and their son Paul Atreides
as well as the servants and teachers
employed by them the harkonnens with the
help of the Emperor sardick our soldiers
staged a coup in which Paul and Jessica
must escape into the deep desert and
Leto is captured presumably to be killed
Paul and his mother Jessica must then
use their bene Jesuit training and
secret knowledge to survive in the
harshest conditions possible and along
the way they gain the support of the
Fremen people of the desert as I said
before the lady Jessica is a bene Jesuit
she was trained by the Reverend Mother
Gaius Helen Mahima when the bene Jesuit
Order realized that duped link two of
Caledon required a concubine they used
their considerable influence to make
sure the lady Jessica was chosen
the Atreides bloodline contained genes
that were highly important to the
sisterhood
Jessica's orders were to bear only
daughters to the Duke Leto Jessica broke
this order instead she bore a son and
trained him in the many Jesuit way
whilst at the same time his father the
Duke was having him trained as a mint at
the mint at our the human computers of
the Imperium capable of incredible feats
of calculation in milliseconds Paul was
already the result of millennia of
selective breeding at the hand of the
Bene Jesuit this coupled with his
training he was something more than a
mini generate much more by mistake a
generation too soon the many Jesuit had
birthed the keyset hadurok the
universe's super being he who could be
in many places at once he with perfect
vision but there was still uncertainty
to unlock his full potential Paul would
need to be tested by the truth Sayer
trouble there is a place where no truth
seer can see we are repelled by it
terrorized it is said a man will come
one day and find in the gift of the drug
his inward eye he will look where we
cannot in do both feminine and masculine
past your kiss etcetera yes the one who
can be in many places at once
the key SATs had a rack many men have
tried the drum so many but none has
succeeded they tried and failed all of
them Oh No she shook her head
they tried and died deep in the desert
as Paul in just more of the spice than
he has ever had his initial powers
awakened he knows that one day the
Fremen people of the desert will look to
him as a God Paul sees a jihad in his
name spreading throughout the galaxy
like a raging fire playing in every
inhabited world the religion of MU Adeeb
would spread leaving millions dead in
its wake Paul knew that he was powerless
to stop it the inevitability of the
jihad haunts Paul throughout the series
Paul and Jessica would have never
survived in the desert and gone on to
liberate the Fremen people and gain
vengeance for House Atreides unseating
the Emperor of the Imperium if not for
the planning of the Binnie jesuit order
the misión ara protect Eva also called
the bene Jesuits black arm of
superstition is a special kind of
religious engineering created by the
bene Jesuit to sow seeds of superstition
in primitive cultures throughout the
galaxies the misión ara protect Eva was
used by The Sisterhood on dune centuries
before House Atreides gain the fiefdom
they sold legends telling that the son
of AB in E jesuit woman would leave the
Fuhrman people to true freedom so when
Paul and Jessica arrived they fit the
legends exactly they were viewed as
legendary figures the Fremen people
named Paul Lee son al gayab the voice
from the outer world he would fulfill
their ancient prophecy the Fremen people
never knew just how much their myths and
led
were influenced by the workings of the
sisterhood in the end Paul Atreides
would rise to Emperor of the known
Imperium marrying the princess Irulan
Kirino
daughter of the Emperor Shaddam the
forth Jessica now a reverend mother
chose to return to Caledon leaving alia
the child of Duke Leto who was born in
the deep desert behind alia was pre born
breaking into consciousness with all the
memories of her ancestors due to her
mother's consumption of the truth singer
drug to the Bene Jesuit such a child is
an abomination alia in many ways was
more unexpected than even Paul himself
born of the same genetic lines alia was
supposed to be Jessica's first child
unremarkable but for the precious genes
she carried but the sisterhood never
intended for Jessica to be on Arrakis
much less undergo the spice agony while
pregnant the result was a child that
could strike fear into the hearts of
even the Reverend mother's of the Binnie
Jesuit that child is an abomination the
old woman said her mother deserves a
punishment greater than any in history
death it cannot come too quickly for
that child or the one who spawned her
the old woman pointed a finger at alia
get out of my mind
TP the emperor whispered he snapped his
attention back to alia by the great
mother you don't understand majesty
the old woman said not telepathy she is
in my mind she is like the ones before
me the ones who gave me their memories
she stands in my mind she could not be
there but she is
what others the Emperor demanded what is
this nonsense
the old woman straightened lowered her
pointing hand I have said too much but
the fact remains that this child who is
not a child must be destroyed long were
we warned against such a one and how to
prevent such a birth but one of our own
has betrayed us
nopal married ear alone his concubine
Johnny a freeman woman was his true love
she bares Paul to children Leto the
second named for Paul and aleeah's
father and ghanima whose name meant
spoil of war later the second would go
further than even Paul would and his
influence would echo to the edges of
time itself
the spice melange is produced by the
great sand worms of Arrakis if they
should die then all spice production
would cease the sand worms are monstrous
beings that roam in the deep desert they
attack all rhythmic motions such as
footsteps or the rumbling of spice
harvesters the worm is now beneath the
crawler kind said you are about to
witness a thing few have seen flecks of
dust shadow the sand around the crawler
now the big machine begin to tip down to
the right
a gigantic sand whirlpool begin forming
there to the right of the crawler it
moved faster and faster sand and dust
filled the air now for hundreds of
meters around then they saw it a wide
hole emerged from the sand sunlight
flashed from glistening white spokes
within it the holes diameter was at
least twice the length of the crawler
Paul estimated he watched as the machine
slid into that opening in a billow of
dust and sand the hole pulled back
God's what a monster muttered a man
beside Paul in the book Children of Dune
Leto ii joins with the sand route the
protoform of the sand worms transcending
his own humanity over the course of
three thousand five hundred years later
morphs into the god emperor the closest
thing to a deity that mankind has ever
seen through the golden path Leto leads
humanity to its salvation preventing
trellising the mythic battle at the end
of time that both he and his father
foresaw Leto transformed Arrakis the
Great worms died stopping spice
production space travel was prohibited
without the permission of the god
Emperor the Imperium was at peace all
spice was rationed by Leto himself Leto
rule of the universe with a firmer grasp
than anyone before him his powers of
prescient far outshine those of his
father his genetic memory allowed him to
reach back and see through the eyes of
his ancestors billions of lives lived in
him at all times with an iron fist lay
till the tyrant would teach humanity a
lesson on stagnation when I set out to
lead humankind along my golden path I
promised them a lesson that their bones
would remember I know a profound pattern
which humans deny with their words
even while their actions of ferment they
say they seek security and quite the
condition they call peace even as they
speak they create the seeds of turmoil
and violence if they find their quiet
security they squirm in it
how boring they find it look at them now
look at what they do while I record
these words ha
I give them enduring eons of enforced
tranquillity which plods on and on
despite their every effort to escape
into chaos
believe me the memory of Latos peace
shall abide with them forever they will
seek their quiet security thereafter
only with extreme caution and steadfast
preparation when the tyranny of the worm
god emperor Leto finally ended there was
a great scattering under the rule of the
god Emperor the people of the Imperium
lived peacefully but not happily Leto
had exposed a deep anxiety that existed
within all of humankind a kind of
restlessness deep rooted within a
collected human consciousness when they
were finally allowed to travel
throughout the universe freely humanity
spread well beyond the reaches of the
Imperium into the vastness of space
ensuring the survival and the diversity
of the species but linked Oh had done
something else to humanity he had taken
over the Bene Jesuit breeding program
but used it for a different purpose
after generations of trying Leto created
ciona
only she was blocked from his vision
Leto introduced a no gene into humanity
and following the famine times preceding
Latos death this gene was spread out
through the reaches of space ensuring
that never again could all of humanity
be seen by prescient
Leto foresaw an enemy the great enemy
threatening all of humanity something
that would use prescient to seek out and
destroy all of humanity by breeding this
no gene Leto saved humanity from this
threat at his death Leto ii went back
into aratus the individual sand trout of
his skin separating and returning to the
sands the new worms that would form from
them would each have a piece of the god
emperor inside they would be more
intelligent and more terrible than the
worms of ancient Arrakis the events of
the last two novels in Frank Herbert's
original doom saga take place 1,500
years after the death of the god Emperor
at this point the planet Arrakis which
had been terraformed by the god emperor
has returned to desert the great sand
worms have returned and brought with
them a new flow of the spice melange a
new civilization has arisen during the
chaos of the famine times and the great
scattering a civilization containing
three dominant powers the exceeds who's
no ships are capable of piloting between
the stars without the use of spice
melange the Bene tail acts who've
learned to manufacture spice in their
axolotl tanks and have created a new
breed of shape-shifting face dancers and
of course the ever-evolving
many Jesuit sisterhood
and it is also at this time a millennia
and a half after the death of Leto the
second that son from the scatterer began
to return among them are the honored
matriz a violent matriarchal order of
women bred and trained for combat and
the sexual control of men they seek to
control the old Empire with violent
force and gained many jesuit knowledge
lost to them the military and sexual
skills possessed by the honored montrezl
seemed to indicate that they are the
result of a combination of the fish
speakers who were the female servants of
late to the second and the Bene Jesuit
who fled out into the scattering 1,500
years earlier an honored ma tree of the
scattering demanded his presence a pot
window of pot Windus descendants of
talaxian the scattering had told him all
they could about these terrible women
far more terrible than the Reverend
mother's of the Bene Jesuit they said
and more numerous woth reminded himself
the honored ma Trey's makes several
attacks on the Binnie Jesuit strongholds
throughout the bounds of the old Empire
eventually the honored ma Trey's destroy
the planet Arrakis itself killing every
sand worm in
distance except for the one the Binney
Jesuit sisterhood escapes with in the
wake of the destruction left by the
honored Mott raise the bene Jesuit now
led by Dario trade a descendant of Paul
Atreides continues to develop her plan
to defeat the Mott raise the bene Jesuit
have shielded their secret planet behind
a wall of no ships which are invisible
to long-range detection and immune to
the powers of prescience it is here that
they begin to breathe the sandworms by
drowning the worm they saved from
Arrakis in a mixture of spice and water
they forced the creature back into its
protoform it becomes a mini sand trout
and so the cycle begins The Sisterhood
Tara forms the planet chapter house to
accommodate the great worms ahead of
this breeding program is she Donna a
girl born on Arrakis who discovered she
had the ability to control the desert
worms at this point the entire tale Axew
civilization has been destroyed by the
matrix
the only remaining survivor is sky tail
who offers up secret tool Axew knowledge
to the bene Jesuit in exchange for
protection from the Mott raise the bene
Jesuit or the first time now have the
tell axis secret of goal of production
which they use to produce a Gola of odd
raids father the Atreides genius
military leader who was killed a book
earlier miles tag a golem is a kind of
clone on chapter house the bene Jesuit
also housed two prisoners a Duncan Idaho
golem produced by the tale Axew this
gola has the memories of all previous
Duncan Idaho golus knowledge stretching
back since the time of Leto the first
and marbella a former honored matron who
the bene Jesuit have taken as a novice
this Duncan Idaho gola also has a kind
of prescient vision in it he glimpses an
older man and woman staring back at him
he is confused by the vision but says
nothing it is revealed in the final
novel that the honored MA trays were
fleeing an unknown enemy out of the
scattering the enemy was powerful and
had conquered the honored matras own
massive Empire it is unclear whether or
not this enemy is the great enemy that
Leto foresaw in the in old raid stages
an attack on the honored montrezl
aggressively striking the planet gamoo
victory seems near for the sisterhood
until the honored mater a release a
mysterious weapon Oh Dre Dre Liza's the
trap too late and is captured in one
final desperate gamble marbella the
former montre who has shared memories
with owed raid pilots a small craft down
to the surface of gamoo announcing
herself as an honored matray who in the
confusion has managed to escape the Bene
Jesuit with all their secrets but when
she came face-to-face with the great
honored montre she used the Vinnie J's
rip our of voice to provoke her your
fluency and lies does not hide them
marbella said she swept a scornful gaze
across the ones behind law known like
the ones I know in other memory you are
headed for extinction the problem is you
take so infernally long at dodging
inevitable but oh the boredom meanwhile
you dare call yourself great honored
montre returning her attention to love
known everything about
a cesspool you have no style it was too
much log no attacked left foot slashing
out work with blinding speed mer Bella
grasp the foot as she would catch a
windblown leaf and continuing the flow
of it levered log no unto a threshing
Club that ended with her head poked on
the floor without pausing mer Bella
Pyrrha wedded let foot almost
decapitating the honored betray who had
stood at lock nose right the right hand
crushing the throat of the one who had
stood at Lanos left it was all over in
two heartbeats marbella kills the
honored Matra leader lob no and awed by
her physical prowess the remaining
matras are forced to accept her as their
leader mer Bella again shares memories
with the dying ode raid becoming the
Mother Superior of the Bene Jesuit as
well joining the two groups of women but
some Bening Jesuit do not accept
marbella ascension Gianna who also
shared memories with ode raid before
leaving chapterhouse escapes into a no
ship where she has brought some of the
new worms which emerged from the
chapterhouse desert she along with
Duncan Idaho site L and miles tagging
marbella realizes their plans too late
and is unable to intervene in the final
chapter of the doomed series it is
revealed that the man and woman glimpsed
in prescience by Duncan Idaho are named
Daniel and Mark II the to refer to
themselves as face dancers who for
thousands of years had been the
shape-shifting minions of the TEL Axew
capable of absorbing memories and taking
the form of other people
they have had such a hard time accepting
that face dancers can be independent of
them I don't see why it's a natural
consequence they gave us the power to
absorb the memories and experiences of
other people gather enough of those and
its personas we take Marty whatever the
master should have known we would gather
enough of them one day to make our own
decisions about our future the two hint
that they observe and are familiar with
various groups in the universe and for
some reason are very interested in
capturing and studying the passengers of
Duncan's no ship the role or purpose of
these two was never revealed in Frank
Herbert's original six doom novels their
technology seems to be almost godlike
Duncan too recognizes them as face
dancers and understands that the two
belong to no one but themselves
the final novel in Frank Herbert's
doomed series ends on a cliffhanger for
Herbert did not live to complete the
seventh novel planned for the series
several questions are left unanswered
what becomes of the merging of the
honored morees and the bene Jesuit what
are the fates of those escaping on the
notion who are these godlike characters
in Chapter houses final chapter and of
course what exactly chased the honoured
montrezl back into the old Empire in the
first place
these are merely the events of the doom
saga doom is a humanist a book series
that is highly concerned with the cycles
of governmental systems doom shows how
the masses can be manipulated the
religion and social engineering New Moon
explores the damage that can be caused
by the joining of government and
religious faith most of all dune exposes
the cycles of humanity and the constant
structure of giving and taking that is
present throughout the universe in the
seven part series I will explore all six
of Frank Herbert's novels in order
deeply delving into the themes and the
underlying meanings and guiding you
through the most intelligent and
well-thought-out sci-fi series ever
written to learn more about the dune
saga check out this video on the Binney
Jesuit the matriarchs who secretly rule
the galaxy
[Music]
there's so much of love graph in
particular where well Lovecraft was all
about those higher mysteries his story
is just kind of
[Music]